welcome back okay so now we're talking
about the eigen system realization
algorithm which is another method of
getting a linear dynamical system that
fits your data so this is purely
data-driven it works for experimental
systems the assumption here is that you
can describe your data with linear
dynamics and that you have an impulse
response okay so that basically means
that my input you I walk it very fast
with some energy I hit my system with a
hammer I measure how my measurements
change in time and hopefully eventually
die out like this and at the end of the
day what I do is I collect that
measurement data Y at time 0 Y at time 1
Y at type 2 and so on and so forth I
measure a time series of Y I've drawn
this is a single input single output
system but in general this could be a
you know vector of inputs and a vector
of outputs I could have three inputs and
ten outputs all of this generalizes
these would just then be little matrix
blocks of size out by in but I collect
this data in pink here okay now if my
assumption of this being a true linear
system this is a linear system but I
don't know what a B C and D are but
there is some linear system under
underlying these dynamics then this y 0
would correspond to the D matrix y 1
would be C B y 2 would be C a B and so
on so there's a corresponding expression
of these measurements in terms of these
unknown matrices that I don't have
access to so the first thing we're gonna
do just really simply is we're just
gonna pull off zy0 the first measurement
and we're gonna call that our D matrix
first thing is first so we have our D
matrix that's easy we have D and now
what we're going to do is we're going to
take Y 1 through Y K where K might be
large we're gonna take these
measurements and we're gonna try to back
out a best fit model for a B and C in
terms of a small state X that's as small
as possible that still captures these if
enough of dynamics very similar in
flavor to balance truncation except that
this is system identification I do not
have access to the model I just have
data whereas balance truncation and
balance
you had you know data and a model to
generate that data okay but the starting
point is actually super similar between
er a and balanced P OD
and so I'll just write this down so what
we do is we take all of this measurement
data and we stack it into a big Hankel
matrix okay this big Hankel matrix is y1
y2 y3 dot dot dot y2 y3 y4 dot dot and
you get the picture you can keep doing
this over and over you hope that you
have enough data that this can be a big
matrix not that and you might ask
yourself well how much data should I
collect basically I want to collect data
until Y approaches zero so if I have a
really lightly damped system this could
be a very large matrix and I also want a
small Delta T so that I capture the fast
time scales okay so this could be a big
matrix but this is basically just your
time series of measurements in a row and
then you shift them over one Delta T
that's your next row you shift them over
Delta T that's your next row and so on
and so forth so this is a big matrix of
course you could write this in terms of
c b c ABC a squared b and so on you
could write this in terms of the unknown
system but for now I just want to be
very clear this is data okay this is a
data matrix H a Hankel matrix what you
can then do is you can then take the
singular value decomposition to figure
out what are the kind of left and right
eigen spaces of this before I do that I
think there's one more thing I want to
show you which is if I plugged in CBC
ABC a squared B in all of this I want to
just remind you that this equals that
curly OH matrix times my curly C matrix
from before where this was my adjoint
impulse response matrix and this was my
direct impulse response matrix now this
was non-physical to get I can't get
access to curly Oh in an experiment I
can't run in
adjoint experiment there's no such thing
as a transpose Hubble okay or a
transpose International Space Station
but I can build this Hankel matrix
nonetheless from data and it is what I
would get if I could run that adjoint
simulation direct modes and adjoint
loads times direct adjoint snapshots
times direct snapshots so this is equal
to that o times C from before when we
were doing balanced p OD allah clancy
Rally 2005 this Hankel is the same as
curly o times curly c from BP OD let's
say from BP idea okay and then what I
can also do I mean I have all this data
I hit the system I measure it for a long
time data's cheap nowadays I can also
measure H prime which is basically all
of this one time step in the future so
it's the same matrix but instead of y1
this is y2 y3 y4 dot dots y3 y4 y5 dot
dot dot dot running out of space okay
but you get the idea it's exactly the
same size as H just shifted one Delta to
you in the future and so y1 becomes Y 2
and so on and so forth it would be cool
to verify you should probably verify
this so remember o is this big matrix of
CCAC a square and CA cubed curly C is a
big matrix B a B a squared B a cube B
you should verify that when you multiply
those together you get this matrix if
you substitute it in all of these blue
terms here ok so anyway I'm starting to
establish that there is a connection
between er a and the balance models that
we talked about earlier basically it's
the exact same Hankel matrix we built
before except I'm building it purely for
measurement data ok and I build H Prime
and I want to point out this is the
important part this is why I introduced
oh and see this is equal to curly o
times the a matrix times curly C so if
you think about what y2 is I mean I'm
going to do this for one of these cases
okay so y1 would be C
be all that y2 is is C a B ok y2 is C a
B all that y3 is is C a squared B all I
do to get H prime is I add an A in the
middle of all of these expressions I
just advance them one more time step by
multiplying with a that's what my
discrete time dynamics are is it is
multiplying by a so I add another a and
I get H Prime and so if I if I could
write this as Oh curly Oh curly C I can
write this as curly Oh a curly C and
what the eigen system realization
algorithm is doing under the hood is
essentially we're trying to take H this
is date H prime this is data we have
we're trying to approximate the left
eigen space the left singular vectors of
O and we're trying to approximate the
right singular vectors of C and we're
gonna try to unwrap this and isolate a
we're going to try to solve for a from H
and from these eigenspaces so that's
what we're really doing and this is also
going to further establish that
connection to it to balance truncation
okay I hope everyone's with me so far
we have data we built a matrix we built
another matrix that's all we've done so
far all of the other stuff is just the
framing I have data and I built H and H
Prime that's step one step one is
collect the data step two is build H and
H Prime step three is take the singular
value decomposition of H and I'm gonna
do this exactly like I did before I have
you Sigma V I'm just gonna call it
transpose it's complex conjugate
transpose but let's just use transpose
and just like before in balanced p OD
i'm going to write this as my first are
columns of u the dominant modes the
dominant left singular vectors times all
the stuff i'm going to truncate i'm
gonna have the same thing for sigma
dominant and then sigma truncate and i'm
gonna have v i don't want to draw this
probably vertically v tilde transpose
and everything i'm going to truncate
transpose okay this is exactly what we
did with balanced p OD
we built this Henkel matrix but we did
it from direct and adjoin snapshots we
took its singular value decomposition
this is going to come back time and time
again so there's a new method we've
developed called the Henkel alternative
view of Koopman for non-linear systems
it's also going to be in terms of an SVD
of a Hanko matrix so we're gonna do this
a lot we build a Hankel matrix these are
time series data I take the singular
value decomposition of that time series
data and I get a set of dominant columns
in U and a set of these dominant rows in
V transpose and those are my dominant
eigen time series kind of rows and
columns that best describe this H matrix
so I can approximate this if my singular
values drop off fast I can throw away
all these truncated things and it's
still pretty good approximation with the
U tilde sigma tilde B tilde transpose to
this and maybe I can do that with five
columns and 5 rows instead of a thousand
okay that's them that's where the the
reduction is gonna come in okay
collected data built in matrix took the
SVD now what are we going to do so this
is where it's gonna get a little hairy
and I'm not going to walk you through
all of the steps because there's a lot
of them and it would take a lot of time
but you can go back to the original
paper or you could go to MA and rally
2011 tea CFD or you can go look in the
book and work this out in in detail okay
so we're going to use U tilde to kind of
factor out this o matrix and we're going
to use V tilde to kind of factor out
this C matrix and we're going to try to
solve for a so that's what we're gonna
do basically once I've collected my data
built my matrices and taken the SVD I
can go directly to building a model so
that's what I'm gonna do okay so now I
have all this stuff I'm going to build
my model and my model is going to be a
tilde B tilde C tilde this is going to
be a rank R model so I'm going to choose
this truncation I'm going to choose
are based on Sigma okay so if you were
actually doing this in practice you
collected your data you built this
matrix you took the SVD what you should
do is you should plot the singular
values and see where you can truncate
what is the good r where you can
truncate those singular values yeah that
are and so we pick an R so that we
capture most of the input-output energy
of this most of the Hankel singular
values are in those first R and then I'm
gonna build these a tilde B tilde C
tilde matrices from data that I already
have so what am I gonna do I'm gonna say
a tilde is and this is a hairy
expression I always forget this so its
Sigma tilde minus 1/2 u tilde transpose
H prime v tilde sigma tilde 1/2 minus
1/2 okay it's a hairy expression but I
just want to impress on you this is a
symmetric matrix okay H is a symmetric
matrix so there is some inherent
symmetry of use and Vees and the Sigma
so I can kind of split this so what I'm
doing is I'm splitting u tilde sigma one
half sigma one half v tilde and i'm
inverting that i'm trying to I'm calling
that oh and sit and see and I'm trying
to I'm trying to basically multiply by
Oh inverse and C inverse to isolate a if
I could multiply this by au inverse and
C inverse I get an A that's what I'm
trying to do here very hand wavy but
there's kind of rigorous math to back up
what we're doing here B tilde also kind
of a funny expression its Sigma tilde
now to the positive 1/2 times V tilde
transpose times this funky matrix which
is the identity the P by P identity
matrix times 0 times 0 I'll tell you
what this means in a minute it's it's
kind of a mess and C tilde is similarly
a Q by Q identity matrix 0 0 0 now
times u tilde times Sigma tilde 1/2 okay
now the reason I have this thing here is
basically because I can only have ki I
only have P inputs and I have Q outputs
I think I should swap pinky it doesn't
matter whatever whatever the number of
inputs in the number of outputs are
that's what I'm doing here because this
Sigma tilde to the one-half V tilde T
this is a rank R these are rank R
matrices but I might have R equals 10 I
mean 10 hidden states X but I might only
have 2 inputs so I select the first two
columns of this B tilde of this matrix
to get B tilde similarly I select the
first Q rows of this rank R matrix to
get to get see there's some fancy stuff
going on under the hood but this is a
procedure okay so step 1 collect the
data step 2-1 to build your Hankel
matrices in H prime step 3 you can take
the SVD and step 4 you directly get a
reduced order model a tilde B tilde C
tilde very useful you can do this
directly from data this is why this is
my go to linear system identification
method because it's super simple
you collect impulse response data you
build these matrices taken SVD and you
have dynamics ok and this a tilde B
tilde C tilde is I mean very much in the
in the vein of balance truncation this
is a very good model it's one of the
best models you can get for rank R that
describe this system ok and you choose
that rank by looking at these Henkel
singular values and seeing kind of how
much how many modes are necessary to
describe the dynamics ok so the last
thing I'm going to show you is basically
that you can actually write down the
system model so then you know X tilde K
plus 1 equals a tilde X K plus B tilde u
K Y cake will see tilde X K Plus D u K
and remember I grabbed this D matrix it
was my first
a tilde B tilde C tilde come through
this er a procedure so this is a
discovered model we literally had data
and we discovered this model that best
fits the data this is essentially a
regression that it finds the best fit a
tilde B tilde C tilde and D that match
that impulse response data for a given
rank are very cool I can collect
measurement data and I can essentially
find a model that describes that data
notice these are all tilde X's I don't
know what these states mean these tilde
states are in terms of eigen time-delay
coordinates it says weird Metta state X
that I might not have a physical
interpretation for but it is the hidden
state and the hidden dynamics that are
necessary it's somehow abstracts in the
case of the Hubble Space Telescope it's
abstracting all of these rich elastic
waves into a few modes a few dominant
shapes that you can superpose with
different eigen values to get that input
output dynamics that's what the eigen
system realization algorithm does it's
very closely connected to BPO D because
you can write it in terms of these
direct and adjoin snapshot matrices and
that connection has been established to
show that this really is the same model
you would get with BPO D if under some
assumptions ok thank you